elodie car disent bonjour vous êtes la
responsable du musée rambo litres a donc
à rambouillet est consacrée au train
alors lui votera je suppose que vous
étiez pas là il ya 31 ans quand ça c'est
créer effectivement non moi je suis
arrivé il ya à peu près une dizaine
d'années ouais un peu par hasard
d'autant que le train qui est derrière
nous voilà un peu par hasard aussi je
voulais travailler dans un musée à faire
des animations pour les enfants vient
des visites guidées voilà et il s'est
trouvé que dans ce musée on cherchait
quelqu'un qui était par ailleurs à 30 km
de chez moi donc ça c'est donc ça
c'était bien
racontez nous un peu d'histoire quand
même de ce musée comment il a été
condamné ces normes l'histoire même si
vous étiez alors l'histoire du musée
donc c'est il faut ça remonte à ya 31
ans effectivement en 84 mais en réalité
ça remonte même un petit peu avant
puisque il a fallu dix ans à peu près
avant que le musée soit ouvert il ya eu
en fait deux personnes à l'origine de ce
musée donc alain baldy qui était
passionné de maquettes et jacques
visbecq y avait une maison à rambouillet
avec une énorme collection de trains ah
oui déjà
voilà donc qui a donné à la ville de
rambouillet sa maison et sa collection
et c'est comme ça que le musée a été
créé par la rencontre de ces deux
passionnés après il ya eu une volonté
politique un peu au hasard parce qu'on
se dit rambouillet pourquoi un musée du
jouet pour le lien rambouillet williams
gagna
bon je m'égare le fait il ya eu la
maison de ce collectionneur qui a donné
à rambouillet et rambouillet avaient
déjà leur donnant un peu de l'historique
grâce au changement naturel grâce au à
la forêt donc ils ont voulu ajouter un
atout un peu plus patrimoniale et plus
culturel avec ce musée et c'est comme ça
que sa venue à musique municipale voilà
tout à fait en 84 alors commence à se
développer donc au départ ces deux
passionnés actionné sa donc ils ont déjà
des trains ils ont déjà des des wagons
enfin des deux co motive donc y met et
qui veulent montrer aux comics c'est ça
en fait j'avais enfin on a on amuse et
du train miniature
il ya deux pôles principaux ici nous
sommes au deuxième étage sur le réseau
mac est donc le réseau maquette
il a été constitué au fur et à mesure
donc à partir de 84 jusqu'à maintenant
aujourd'hui voilà par l'association du
musée notamment et par alain bali
effectivement il y avait quelques
maquettes qui ont été donnés dans la
collection
mais le plus gros voilà a été fait au
fur et à mesure bic au cinéma voilà tout
est fait une main tu t'es fait parler de
son travail et en main et après en ce
qui concerne le matériel roulant
il ya des choses à acheter tout fait il
y a des choses qui arrivent en kit que
l'on monte les décors où ils sont
toujours fait part par l'association par
le par les gens du musée
voilà c'est comme ça ekobo alors on
récupère puisqu'on est dans les
miniatures
parlant des miniatures il ya des dons il
ya des il ya des achats commenté ross en
maquette siala des fabrications voilà il
ya plus tôt
des achats j'ai dis vivement
tout est fait à la main donc tard on va
dire plutôt des grands noms de la
maquette que ça peut être en italie ça
peut être en suisse
beaucoup de suisses mais tout est
vraiment faire la main donc un très
petit nombre d'exemplaires
donc ça c'est alors au fond ça donc
c'est vraiment le matériel roulant
puisque tout le reste vous le
retrouverez nulle part ailleurs puisque
le décor est fait pour ici bien sûr
après on achète les personnages par
exemple mais que l'on peint nous mêmes
et les décors qui sont à l'intérieur des
voitures on dit voiture pour les
voyageurs et vacances et d'argent du les
intérieurs sont fait par nous mêmes
aussi il ya combien de personnes comme
ça qu'ils disent au cube qui sont des
passionnés
c'est des passionnés une rose un à
l'association on est à peu près 60 mais
il ya un petit noyau dur qui est là tous
les mardis le jour de fermeture et ils
sont à peu près 8 à travailler un peu
sur le réseau et qui qui fabrique qui
entretiennent voirie décor droit est
fait par le fondateur du musée par
l'ancien directeur monsieur van dit
alain badie voilà qui est ce à la
retraite mais qui est toujours ici pour
vous est-ce que dont les dans les
maquettes il ya il ya des pièces
dont vous êtes fier que d'autres vous
êtes extrêmement fiers de montrer aux
nôtres vous à peu près tout mais on a
plus de fierté dans le jouet que dans la
maquette en fait parce que là on a parlé
effectivement du côté maquette on est à
7 et achi mais le gros de la collection
qui a été donnée celle étage en dessous
le premier avec que du jouet et là on
raconte l'histoire du trajet du train
joué par nom de 1860 on va dire à 1956
si on sait que ça le au fossat sort des
presses que la création du train on en
fait aussi un jeu oui c'est ça c'est ça
c'est les premiers jouets en fait
pendant ce temps les petits garçons ont
joué quasiment contraint y avait rien
d'autre
aujourd'hui on trouve quasiment plus de
trains jouer d'une belle callas des
collectionneurs il ya des magasins
spécialisés mais il ya en effet 7 mai
des plus beau cadeau qu'on peut bien
quoi les enfants jouent mieux que le
train mais pendant ce temps en temps ils
ont vraiment joué autres donc cela on
n'est plus fière de cette collection
puisqu'on et musées de france et on est
unique en france aussi avoir cette
collection cette collection de jouets gi
qui est-ce qui fait les premiers de
premier joué par les premiers jouets été
fait par les faire blanchir qui faisait
à l'époque des bassines des lessiveuses
et avec les chutes
ils vont en fait fabriquer les premiers
trains jouer donc tous les trains jouer
son fer en fer blanc quasiment d'accord
et elle reste magnifique parce que c'est
l'heure les jouets évidemment ça suit
l'évolution du tripot agir on voit quoi
il y ait des vapeurs il ya bien
il ya des trains les premiers chevet de
1860 à peu près c'est des trains a
traîné c'est comme ça que je vois les
premiers enfants
on avait un trou à l'avant on mettait
une ficelle et enfants tirés centre
c'est ça voilà mettez pas les clubs
c'est basique c'est ça en plus ça
déforme naïve des couleurs naïve on se
retrouve avec des wagons un peu môme on
se demande si ça a vraiment existé à
l'époque mais ça ce côté voilà naïf mais
très sympathique qu'on est bien en
jouets anciens
après à partir de 1880 on invente le
train à vapeur en jouit donc là les ans
des gens imaginent et joue avec une
bouteille d'alcool liquide et avec des
allumettes
donc ça c'est très bruyant que sa bande
et vous est-ce que c'est déjà parce que
c'est trop fou c'est l'histoire de sa du
doubs et du train c'est que c'est fait
pour les enfants soit disant mais je
pense que les parents qui les offrent
s'amuse aussi avec dire que c'est un
jouet qui qui qui qui grandit avec les
personnes qui errent à on peut penser
des collectionneurs évidemment mais fin
des gens l'adulte qui jouait beaucoup
avec des trains dont j'apprends encore à
cette époque la banque à cette époque-là
en 1880 sait encore vraiment les encore
de 10 ou 12 ans vont évidemment le train
vapeur c'est cher mais pas en fer blanc
évidemment ça en laiton c'est dangereux
et c'est très cher donc peu d'enfants
vont en avril après on a le train
mécanique en 1890 là on remonte le
mécanisme à ressort avec une clé donc
c'est déjà un peu mieux et à partir de
1900 on a le train électrique déjà et
ces voix là et c'est là que les papes
avons commencé à jouer au train et
surtout dans les années 30 puisque le
train électrique va voir si vous voulez
la représentation d'un vrai train alors
qu'avant c'est plutôt naïf il n'y a pas
forcément bon il deux roues ça se
rapproche plus au fur et à mesure de la
maquette avec du détail
on commence à vraiment éviter la réalité
des trains est ce qu'il t'est étude
psychologique aux enfants qui auraient
été faites pour savoir pourquoi il y
avait cette fascination
c'est le premier moyen de transport
c'est la révolution industrielle s'est
il ya plein de choses à apprendre avec
le tram c'est fascinant vrai
qu'aujourd'hui quand on voit tous les
accessoires qu'on a pour jouer aux
trains afin qu'on avait pour jouer au
train à l'époque on peut retracer toute
l'histoire du train il est vrai train
donc c'est quand même fabuleux on a plus
ça aujourd'hui
il faudrait penser pour l'enfance est
pensé pour l'enfant donc on peut
retracer l'histoire du train à travers
le jouer on entend à travers l'histoire
du jouet qui reproduit et qui reproduit
de plus en plus fidèle finalement quand
la réalité c'est ça puisque on parle de
choses qui sont un peu de tout et qui
leur arrive
on voit quand même on voit sa mission
d'être encore et là aussi alors dans le
musée du jouet à ce qu'il y avait des
pièces dont vous êtes le plus fier ce
corps pas mal de questions on est fiers
on a notamment quelques belles
locomotives à vapeur qui ressemble plus
vraiment à des maquettes qui a déjoué
puisque je sais c'est assez volumineuse
luis avait fait part des ferblantiers au
départ et pas ou sinon par des
agriculteurs ont des choses comme ça il
n'avait pas la dextérité ou les outils
pour faire de la miniature c'est pour ça
que la miniature est arrivé plus tard et
plastiques a permis de miniaturiser de
plus en plus
mais au départ on pouvait pas trop
miniaturisés donc les premiers jouets
sont quand même assez volumineux les
locomotives à vapeur dont je suis la
plus grosse comme ça
ça c'est des pieds secs sont rares oui
ça c'est rare très activement qu'aux
commandes comment vous les procurer
alors ça s'est joué à la wii si on la d2
il ya des comment ça se passait plutôt d
achat d achat mais c'est des locomotives
qui sont quand même assez cher plus est
ancien plus c'est cher surtout à cette
époque là il ya des choses plus récentes
qui sont chers aussi après ça dépend de
plein de critères en fait une locomotive
qui a fait rêver
par exemple un crocodile lemarque ligne
aile et pas forcément rare mais elle a
fait rêver donc elle se vend assez cher
après des locomotives par exemple à 140
et une psg j'aime qui est une marque
très connue celle qui se vend très cher
moi je trouve mais tout simplement parce
qu'elle a des roues en zamac et c'est un
alliage en fait qui ne tient pas bien
dans la durée donc beaucoup ont été
abîmés donc en attendant bon état elle
devient cher donc c'est vraiment
aléatoire on peut faire une vente aux
enchères où on a une locomotive commune
qui va faire vingt mille euros parce que
ce jour-là il ya ce collectionneur qui
est là et qui veut cette locomotive et
qui va faire grimper les enchères est un
autre jour là trouver un peu moins cher
sa défense et souvent aux enchères vous
trouvez les enchères après on a la
chance quand même monsieur baldy qui a
créé le musée est quand même très connu
et le musée est très connu donc quand il
ya des
vente ou des collectionneurs qui vendent
des jouets qu'ils savent qu'on ne les a
pas en général on est au courant
donc on a une sorte de priorité alors un
mot sur le sur le musée
sur son fonctionnement il est ouvert
tous les jours pratiquement du mercredi
au dimanche
dimanche toute l'année oui on est fermé
juste deux semaines début janvier
sinon on est tout le temps là et le
public c'est quoi alors c'est plutôt ya
les enfants naturellement
alors il ya vraiment tout ça peut aller
des grands-parents avec les petits
enfants que là on a aussi le public de
collectionneurs soit de maquettiste qui
viennent voir lama qu'elle soit de
collectionneurs de jouets et puis
quelques fois on a carrément les deux
les grands-parents collectionneurs qui
viennent avec les petits enfants ou tout
simplement les gens qui ont envie de
faire partager ce qu'ils ont connu quand
il était plus jeune
on a vraiment tous les publics c'est le
cas à gré abl vous disiez vous avez
raison c'est que ces voilà le cadeau du
train électrique ça s'est un peu perdu
malheureusement il ya d'ailleurs plus
beaucoup beaucoup de fabricants je peux
aujourd'hui l'art kling persiste voilà
quelques quelques marques comme qui
persistent varela - kindia mail
est ce que quand vous voyez les enfants
ce qui sont fascinés encore par sa où
ils sont vraiment fasciné c'est
quelquefois on a des pleurs d'enfants
qui ne veulent pas partir
ça leur fait toujours autant mais c'est
vrai quand tu fais une visite guidée
avec un groupe d'enfants je leur demande
à la fin s'il préfère leur console wii
train ils ont quand même tendance à
préférer la console c'est bien mais mais
enfin c'est oui il aurait cessé comme ça
doit aussi la différence un peu entre
l'arrêt puis pascal la danse énoncés oui
reconstruction danser jouer dans cette
façon de l'année jouer les édifices qui
font vraiment penser on a une verrière
notamment en bas dont on est fier aussi
art nouveau complètement qui en vaut
pour grand écartement donc lé rendre
comme ça elle est vraiment tout en vert
et on a l'impression de voir un objet
d'art plutôt qu'un jouet les enfants
étaient vraiment gâtés et avait de la
chance je vous précise infinie mots là
bas on n'a plus qu'à inciter tout le
monde à venir à rambouillet c'est place
jeanne d'arc c'est très facile à trouver
en face l'église juste en face de
l'église
et ça ça va le robot litre 1
qui a trouvé ce c'est un peu c'est
l'alliance en bouillie axa s'est
toujours et moi je pense que c'est
l'ancien directeur avec le donateur jeu
preuve merci infiniment et le dkr vi